hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar study design how and when to use
multiplexed immunofluorescence imaging
in your research
i am antonina salcido of labrutz and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by leica microsystems
to learn more please visit leica
microsystems
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues into this
ask a question box
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
melinda angus hill lead scientist and
application manager for cell dive at
leica microsystems
melinda you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the introduction
i'm melinda ingest hill and i am lead
scientist for cell dive at leica
microsystems
today i'll discuss an important topic
surrounding how and when to use
multiplexed immunofluorescence imaging
in your research
translational research is critical to
understanding how scientific
observations relate to human health
in translational research animal models
are commonly used following a thorough
justification for their use including
replacement refinement and reduction of
animal experimentation
animal models are often required when
considering a more systems based
approach to translational research
recently however the availability of
high quality clinically relevant human
tissue has increased
these biobank samples are linked to
de-identified clinical information as
clinical trial participants often
consent to researcher access to their
tissue samples outside of the clinical
trial
while access to high quality clinically
relevant human tissue has improved
dividing the tissue among multiple
researchers often limits the scope of
the research that can be conducted but
still this means that more researchers
can gain access to these rich tissue
samples for translational research
but new technologies including rna-seq
mass spec or multiplexed
immunofluorescence imaging can enable
multiplex quantification of biomolecules
even with minimal amounts of tissue
since high quality samples are precious
implementing a robust study design is
essential to improve the value
of the biomedical information that's
derived from the tissue whether mouse or
human
this webinar will focus on study design
and considerations for planning a study
including experimentation and when and
how to use multiplexed
immunofluorescence in your research
i'll introduce aspects for my
translational research in my lab using
mouse models of colon cancer to
understand human disease the purpose of
this
is to demonstrate where the availability
of multiplexed immunofluorescence would
have improved the use of resources and
shortens the time from research question
to results
commercially available multiplexed
imaging and analysis systems are only
recently becoming robust and accessible
therefore consideration of study design
and research questions is essential
before investing in these technologies
my lab was interested in the early
stages of tumor initiation and cancer
prevention
which led us to the field of mind-body
medicine or stress reduction in cancer
prevention in this field researchers use
prospective studies to survey
participants on behaviors and compare
survey results to outcomes
these studies are becoming more
prevalent over the last 20 years
research in mind-body medicine with
cancer patients and survivors and cancer
prevention is still increasing
embarking on prospective cohort study
for mind-body intervention is very
expensive
it can take years to complete
here the application of a mind-body
intervention in a subset cohort of
individuals is followed by
years of analysis into whether the
intervention affected the outcome in
this case cancer prevention
as daunting as these prospective studies
seem using mouse models as an
alternative for mind-body medicine
studies can be an effective way to study
cancer prevention mice have very similar
biological aspects to humans but mice
are inbred and so are genetically
similar which reduces many inherent
variables within the study
mice can also be genetically manipulated
we developed a mouse model of colon
cancer that combined genetic mutations
that are commonly found in human colon
cancer over 85 percent of human sporadic
colorectal tumors arbor mutations in the
apc gene and a subset of those also have
mutations in the tcf4 gene which is
called tcf7l2 in humans
and tcf7l2 is also strongly associated
with type 2 diabetes
while mouse models can be effective for
mind-body intervention
conducting the study can still take
years to complete from breeding a study
population to running the study defining
outcomes and molecular mechanisms that
underlie the results while reducing
variables is essential for this type of
research unforeseen issues that can
affect the stress levels in the animals
can destroy the experiments so including
construction or changes in diet that can
affect the research outcomes
my point here is that with the goal of
replacement refinement and reduction in
animal research the biological materials
are precious so technologies aimed at
understanding biomolecules in the tumor
microenvironment
must not be sample intensive
therefore good study design is essential
to prevent the loss of months or even
years on research with limited
biomedical value
robust study design is critical to any
study with tissues that are derived from
a population with specific treatments
and associated outcomes
in an in an environmental rich
enrichment study we applied stress
reduction techniques to mouse models of
human cancer here mice had access to
toys and exercise
and other animals in an enriched
environment you can see many of the
animals taking full advantage of this
enriched environment
non-treatment control animals were
housed in an environment with few
animals and limited enrichment
opportunity
a colleague biostatistician stated that
many researchers only consider the
sample size required for significance
after a study is complete and are often
disappointed to find that their study
was underpowered while these
underpowered studies can still be
helpful to provide sample size
information for future studies you
should consider sample size in the study
design phase for example we compete
completed a smaller proof of concept
study to inform sample numbers necessary
for a more significant environmental
enrichment study
it's also essential to have a
well-formulated hypothesis so you can
acquire the appropriate samples
for example since mutant tcf7l2 is
associated with human colorectal cancer
and type 2 diabetes we collected samples
to explore the role of environmental
enrichment on tcf dependent phenotypes
beyond hypothesis-driven science we also
collected stool and tissue for omics
type experiments using rna-seq and
microbiome sequencing
an essential part of sample collection
is to ensure that enough sample is
available to address the research
question
also what controls are crucial including
technical and biological
replicates
the amount of tissue required to explore
biomarkers must define be defined early
on for multiplex imaging experiments
especially if the method is tissue
destructive
and then finally considering how you'll
analyze the data is essential during the
study design phase for multiplexed
imaging studies
if using ai based methods model training
requires a subset of samples for
annotation and training and here those
samples must be similar to those used in
the study including representatives from
a cohort of treated and non-treated
individuals that won't be part of the
study
in the case of a retrospective cohort
study a researcher is limited to samples
collected at the time of the study and
of the associated clinical data even in
the absence of physical samples clinical
information is a component of a robust
study design
often tissue is available without
associated clinical data this material
can still be valuable as technical
controls within a study as i described
in the example of ai model training for
analysis
conventional therapies in the emerging
field of immunotherapy have expanded the
immediate need to understand
immune tumor cells within the tumor
micro environment
in preclinical or retrospective studies
characterizing existing biomarkers or
identifying new biomarkers with
potential predictive value may improve
patient stratification and therefore
affect future patient therapies
i'd like to take a few minutes to
consider study design in these biomarker
studies with biomarker studies
considering sample numbers before the
study begins is the most critical part
of study design with low patient numbers
you may compromise the predictive value
of the model
again consulting with biostatistician
before the study begins will help to
calculate the sample size needed to
obtain significant results
for example suppose the study is to
define predictive value of a biomarker
in that case considerations for sample
size calculations will require an
understanding of the prevalence of the
biomarker in the positive and the
control populations
a smaller exploratory study to
understand biomarker prevalence can
guide sample calculations for a more
extensive study
beyond sample calculations it's also
important to consider sample format and
tumor heterogeneity for sample format
will the entire tissue section or tumor
course be used in a study
comparing heterogeneous and
non-heterogeneous tumors with tumor
cores will require an estimation of how
many cores are needed to sample the
heterogeneity accurately in addition how
will the data be handled to reflect that
heterogeneity you must consider these
issues before the study begins to
prevent drawing incorrect conclusions
from the data
finally to improve the quality of
biomarker studies there are guidelines
called the reporting recommendations for
tumor marker prognostic studies or
remark guidelines
the links to these guidelines
and publications are here
once the study design is complete and
you've conducted a well-powered study
and samples are collected you can
explore research questions considered
during the study design process
back to the pre-clinical mind-body
enrichment studies
we set out to define whether exposure to
a stimulating environment extended the
lifespan of tumor-bearing animals and we
found significant improvement in
lifespan in both male and
female-enriched animals an extension of
55 and 82 days
that's an impressive increase of one
quarter to one third of their lifespan
the mechanism behind this increased
lifespan was unclear but still in male
mice environmental enrichment reduced
systemic levels of two inflammatory
biomarkers suggesting that the mechanism
may involve reduced inflammation
while i'm not showing the data here the
reduced inflammation was not due to
reduced tumorogenesis there were no
significant differences in the tumor
size or tumor load of enriched compared
to non-enriched animals
moving to the next chapter of the study
we work to define the underlying
mechanism behind the effects of
environmental enrichment on improving
the lifespan of tumor-bearing animals
anyone that's done research knows that
often results are negative this study is
no exception
i've intentionally left this slide to
represent these negative findings we had
a well-formed hypothesis that the
improvement in lifespan was related to
the role of tcf and type 2 diabetes and
metabolism but this line of experiments
resulted in negative results
still publication of these negative
results was essential for demonstrating
the mechanism for lifespan extension
following stress reduction is not
related to the role of tcf in diabetes
and metabolism
though most investigation up to this
point on the mechanism that underlies
improvement in lifespan was negative the
crucial preliminary data that i
discussed earlier pointed to the role of
reduced systemic inflammation as part of
the underlying mechanism
a reduction in inflammation is a key
step in the wound repair process the
wound repair process is an orchestrated
program involving multiple cell types
required to heal the wound including
normalized blood vessels
re-epithelialization tissue remodeling
reduce inflammation and scar formation
tumors resemble wounds that do not heal
due to the inability to resolve the
wound repair process
therefore we formulated a new hypothesis
that colon tumor-bearing animals housed
in a stimulating environment have
improved lifespan due to the resolution
of the wound repair process and reduced
systemic inflammation
to begin to explore this hypothesis we
turned to rna-seq
embarking on an rna-seq experiment is
expensive especially with dozens or
hundreds of samples
it's essential to approach these
experiments in a hypothesis-driven way
to ensure that you consider the
appropriate controls and possible
outcomes
our rna-seq experiment compared normal
and tumor tissue isolated from the
colons of tumor-bearing animals in
enriched or standard housing
environments
perhaps most important for rna-seq
experiments is to consider how you will
analyze the data for example to help
understand the complex disease-related
data that we collected from this study
and apply statistical methods to the
analysis we use kaijin's ingenuity
pathway analysis or ipa
ipa enables researchers to move beyond
expression changes in single transcripts
towards expression changes in pathways
disease state or function among others
this type of analysis is essential given
the systems-based research question
in the end a well-formulated experiment
can help to reveal the mechanism and new
biology that you can further test to
move beyond the descriptive cataloging
of expression changes
once you've collected your rna-seq data
you can begin the analysis
i once heard a statement from an
individual in a biotech company that
they don't have time to spend months
analyzing rna-seq data still moving
beyond simple cataloging of expression
change is essential
and while data analysis is labor
intensive many tools exist to speed the
process without compromising the
experiment
for example by using ipa to define
disease and pathway-centric rna
expression changes it was apparent that
while environmental enrichment did not
statistically alter tumor size we
observed reduced expression of genes
that are commonly expressed in colon
cancer and tcf4 and apc are negative
regulators of this pathway these results
suggested that at the cellular level the
tumors were moving towards a more benign
state taken together with a systemic
reduction in inflammation i showed
earlier this epithelialization within
the tumor pointed to an activated wound
repair process
in colon tumors angiogenesis results in
tortuous leaky vessels whereas
enrichment results in tumors with
expression patterns consistent with
normalized vasculature
finally enrichment increases the
expression of markers of the parasite
lineage a multi-potent cell type that
surrounds and stabilizes vessels and is
important in tissue remodeling and scar
formation again these transcriptional
changes are consistent with activation
of the wound repair process
the rna-seq data helped refine the
hypothesis and we set out to directly
test the hypothesis using biomarker
imaging studies
to verify and expand our research beyond
the descriptive cataloging of rna-seq
changes we utilized a traditional tissue
imaging approach for biomarkers with
altered expression in enriched
tumor-bearing animals compared to
non-enriched animals we used serial
sections from each sample to explore
biomarkers involved in vessel
normalization
re-epithelialization and tissue repair
these experiments were a systems-based
approach to test various aspects of the
hypothesis that environmental enrichment
initiates a tumor wound repair response
for today's webinar i won't go into the
details as this data is published and if
you're interested in the findings i'd
encourage you to visit the biset all
paper
i'm showing these figures to highlight
the work required to explore a handful
of biomarkers across tissue samples at
the end of the work the tissue is
exhausted the results are published and
you move on to setting up subsequent
studies to address further research
questions
fast forward to today
now powerful new methods allow
researchers to ask more questions using
a single tissue section for biomarker
imaging studies
recently there's been a rise in the
technologies that enable multiplexed
imaging replacing the traditional and
sample intensive approach
what is multiplex tissue imaging
with multiplex tissue imaging we begin
with the same tissue block sectioned out
onto a microscope slide but instead of
staining adjacent tissue sections an
iterative workflow uses staining on the
same slide
shown here in this video is a staining
of 15 biomarkers using the cell dive
multiplexed imaging solution
let's put this into perspective by
returning to research in my lab
at the end of the study i described we
had a nice story with new insights into
the mechanism that underlies lifespan
extension in enriched colon tumor
animals
perhaps most surprising was the positive
role of b cells and parasites in
antitumor activity through activation of
the wound repair process
but this was the end of the study since
conventional immunofluorescence methods
results in depletion of the tissue
with new multiplexing technology
researchers require only a single slide
per sample the tissues preserved and the
research can continue along with the
generation of new insights
for example here's a list of additional
questions we'd like to answer but can't
without investing in another
environmental enrichment study
given what i've presented up to this
point there are several aspects of a
multiplex imaging solution that in my
mind are essential to get the most out
of the precious tissue samples
first the multiplexed imaging solution
must be adaptable
my research questions require the use of
antibodies to a unique set of biomarkers
that are likely not available in kit
form this solution must allow me to use
the antibodies i validated on ffpe
sections and will enable me to validate
new antibodies and also round out my
study with additional pre-validated
antibodies
it must be reliable i want data from
every biomarker on every slide to be
reliable to enable me to answer my
research questions
it must be easy to use
there are many multiplexing workflows
where components require hands-on data
manipulation but i want all aspects of
the image processing to be automatic
including imaging corrections alignment
and registration and stitching
the tissue
region that i can image must be flexible
we often image smaller mouse tumors but
also image large biopsies or multiple
samples on a single slide so the
solution must enable imaging of most of
the slide area it must be scalable i
want a solution that can be used for
small studies or with automation for
large studies to optimize the use of the
imager 24 hours a day
and finally the process must be tissue
preserving
what do i mean by tissue preserving i
mean that the multiplexed imaging
process must be gentle so the
fluorescent antibodies that are imaged
in earlier rounds have access to the
same tissue as antibodies imaged in
later rounds
beyond that i want the ability to return
to the same slide weeks or months later
to continue to layer new biomarkers on
top of the existing data for the slide
i'd like to discuss the leica cell dive
multiplexed imaging solution coupled
with the needs i described on the
previous slide
each of the five columns shown here is a
single component of the overall cell
dive solution
i described the need to be adaptable
this adaptability would enable you to
characterize antibodies currently used
in the lab for use in cell dive it's
important to stress that the cell dive
process uses conventional
immunofluorescence techniques on ffpe
sections
so it's likely that the antibodies used
in the lab on ffpe sections will be
compatible with the cell dive process
but new antibodies can be validated so
as part of the cell dive solution a
detailed protocol enables the validation
of new antibodies for your study
to round out a study part of the cell
dive solution provides access to a
validated antibody list of over 350
rigorously validated bodies that are
proven to work with the cell dive
process
next along with validated antibodies a
proven process results from years of
research with many patents covering the
benchwork portion including the slide
preparation process with a patented
antigen retrieval protocol
this process ensures that as many
antigen sites as possible are available
for antibody binding
increasing signal intensity versus
samples prepared by more traditional
means
additionally the process includes the
method that enables iterative staining
which is gentle and tissue preserving
i describe the need to be reliable
flexible and imaging and easy to use
first the cell dive acquisition software
uses instrument calibrations to
implement image corrections to ensure
that small or large regions of interest
are seamlessly stitched and precisely
aligned to enable downstream single cell
analysis
additionally the software was purpose
built for multiplexing with many samples
and many imaging rounds you can imagine
it's challenging to track slides through
a study the cell dive acquisition
software makes it easy to manage many
slides and many studies at a time
the cell dive imager contributes to
reliability flexibility and imaging and
ease of use with the software
it is a robust automated microscope with
customizations to make it a dedicated
tissue imager including an onboard
barcode reader and 5-channel capability
finally as you can imagine collecting
all these beautiful images is just the
beginning we've partnered with indica
labs for analysis and insight generation
from imaging data packed with powerful
analysis modules including an ai module
the halo software is powerful and easy
to use
while discussing multiplexed imaging i'd
like to go into a little more detail
here about slide holders because a slide
holder is essential for any multiplexed
imaging solution
while slide holders must hold slides a
well-designed slide holder can improve a
multiplexed imaging workflow in the next
few minutes i'll explain why
since the slide is removed from and
replaced in a slide holder the holder
must be designed with specifications to
allow precise alignment and registration
between rounds it must be flexible to
enable imaging of the entire tissue
finally i described the need for
scalability while the cell dive imager
is compatible with automated plate
loader a slide holder must also be
compatible with automated plate handling
the dual slide cassette allows imaging
of coverslip samples with consistent
slide placement within the holder
ensuring precise alignment and
registration every time
to improve focus and tissue flatness
instead of imaging through the coverslip
with variable amounts of media and
tissue thickness tissue is imaged
through the slide using a long working
distance objective
the dual slide cassette requires that
slides are coverslipped which can be
time-consuming requires skill and
applies mechanical forces on the tissue
during coverslip removal which which
increases the likelihood of tissue loss
or damage with each decover slipping
step
the optimal solution for a slide holder
will overcome the need for cover
slipping and decover slipping but retain
the ability to section the tissue onto a
slide for processing and imaging since
sectioning tissue onto coverslips for
multiplex imaging is cumbersome and
often ineffective
further the solution must allow the same
slide to be stained repeatedly to enable
the layering of biomarkers over many
weeks or months
to overcome the need to cover slip and d
cover slip we developed the cell dive
clickwell
qlikwell is a unique slide holder that
enables an entirely coverslip free
multiplexed imaging workflow preserving
tissue integrity and streamlining the
staining process
for scalability the precise engineering
of the clickwell allows the removal of
the slide for manual or automated
benchwork steps then placement of the
slide in the click well for imaging
steps or slides can be stained inside
the click well manually or using a
liquid handler and then imaged in the
click well
finally the click while conforms to
multi-well plate standards and is
compatible with any plate handling
robotic arm enabling optimal in imager
use throughout 24 hours the video on
this slide shows how easy it is to use
the click well
next i'll focus on a study comparing
staining and imaging workflows with
these two slide holders here the study
compares the tissue preserving qualities
of the click well to conventional
iterative cover slipping and d cover
slipping there are three different works
blows illustrated here the first
workflow number one on top is the
conventional cover slipping and decover
slipping method the slide has the
coverslip removed and is stained using
an auto stainer following staining the
slide is cover slipped and loaded into
the dual slide cassette for imaging
for the click well workflow in number
three on the bottom the slide remained
in the click wall for the entirety of
the study or for number two in the
middle the slide is removed and stained
in an autostainer and then returned to
the clickwell for imaging
all slides in this study were manually
loaded into the imager and imaged
serially
for this study we stained 28 biomarkers
in 12 imaging rounds
next we wanted to define tissue loss
associated with these different
workflows to do this we compared the
final dappy round for slides stained and
imaged with these three different
workflows to dappy in the baseline round
probability masks in yellow which are
visible in the zoomed image on the top
right annotate areas where dappy is
present in the baseline round and absent
in the final imaging round
here in panel one where samples were
cover slipped and d cover slipped 24
times during the process 1.65
of the tissue
area is absent in the final round
whereas staining using an autostainer
and imaging in the click well number two
here had a five-fold reduction in tissue
loss compared to cover slipping and
decover slipping and then finally the
most tissue preserving workflow is
workflow number three where a slide is
stained and imaged inside the click well
with a 28-fold reduction in lost tissue
area compared to the cover slipped
sample
a further examination of tissue loss in
the coverslip sample
shows that cover slipping and decover
slipping results in a steady increase in
tissue loss from round to round however
with a red circle
following round five something happened
in the process that resulted in a
significant increase in tissue loss this
was possibly caused by mechanical damage
from the coverslip as it was falling off
but tissue loss is only part of the
issue with cover slipping
the second issue is dust and debris from
the cover slipping process
here the first circle in the graph and
the image on the left is round 12
while the second circle on the graph and
the image on the right is round 15. the
yellow arrows mark additional tissue
loss in rounds 13 to 15 compared to
round 12 of cover slipping into cover
slipping and the red arrows mark debris
that appears in round 13 and then
disappears by around 15.
these results demonstrate that tissue
loss and debris are a moving target
throughout imaging
the presence or absence of signal in
each round either through tissue loss or
debris blockage of signal should be
carefully examined when you're using a
coverslip in multiplexed imaging
for example following probability
mapping in each round compared to the
baseline round those cells that fall
into regions with tissue loss or debris
should be removed from all analysis when
defining cell phenotypes
the use of click well in the workflow
drastically reduces these issues
i'd like to take a second to discuss why
this matters with cover slipping and
decover slipping at any moment a
catastrophic issue can result in tissue
loss the colon tissue shown in this
study is robust and adheres well to the
slide and the researchers that conducted
this study are multiplexed imaging
experts if tissue adherence or
researcher skill level is suboptimal
cover slipping and decover slipping will
exacerbate them
for statistical purposes the bottom line
is that you cannot afford to lose tissue
regions or worse whole tissues on slides
clickwell enables experts and
non-experts alike to perform multiplex
imaging i've also spoken a lot about
tissue preservation tissue must be
pristine for more rounds of imaging and
the continued layering of the next set
of biomarkers as your hypothesis evolves
for example in study design a colon
cancer study where a cohort of patients
exhibits a therapeutic response your
hypothesis points differences in the
immune micro environment compared to
non-responders here cell dive multiplex
imaging of slides stained an image in
the click well with 11 biomarkers will
address the cancer immunity and
progression hypothesis
if your research hypothesis next points
to the role of aerobic glycolysis in
therapeutic response you can layer
additional markers to test that
hypothesis
here another seven biomarkers are
layered onto the same slide to address
the new hypothesis
the layering of biomarkers can continue
for example if your hypothesis now
implicates program cell death in
therapeutic response you can layer these
eight biomarkers onto the previous 18
biomarkers this flexibility is critical
to get the most out of your precious
tissue and enable your research
questions to evolve over time
finally
i'd like to wrap up today's webinar by
taking a step back to consider the
trajectory of biomarker discovery
research
biomarker discovery research has
traditionally focused on the next single
biomarker
as a molecular indicator of a clinical
condition
however this approach has limitations as
researchers realize that single
biomarker discovery studies may not
accurately reflect the complexity of
different clinical states and may limit
the translation of the research into the
clinic
the true power of multiplex imaging is
to enable a systems-based approach with
the discovery and identification of a
single biomarker in the biological
context of multiple biomarkers all
assayed together as a system with
spatial context with proper study design
the spatial combinations of biomarkers
become indicators of a clinical state
and can illuminate clinically meaningful
biological interactions
thank you for your time now i'll open it
up for questions
thank you melinda for your informative
presentation we'll now start the live q
a portion of the webinar we also have dr
rick kyle chapterlane cell dive sales
specialist who will be joining melinda
and answering questions today
as a reminder if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
now let's get started
our first question is for melinda
do you have antibodies for mouse tissue
on your list
yes we have a list of about 30
antibodies where species reactivity
includes mouse and these have actually
been validated on mouse tissue
however from our list of 350 validated
human antibodies the special species
reactivity can also include mouse so i'd
say that that's i don't have the exact
number but i'd say that's about what one
third of the list
perfect
um in the next question we have um what
are the struggles you have dealt with
using biomarkers
that's a great question probably the
biggest issue with low expressing
biomarkers
is one of the big issues and then how do
you detect them while retaining
linearity
and kind of the key points of cell dive
is that we've developed methods to
remove the autofluorescence so that the
signal is well above that background and
so that makes the biomarker very easy to
detect
also when you're thinking about study
design we have a lot of recommendations
that allow you to
choose the correct fluorophores with the
correct markers to optimize how to deal
with uh this issue of
low express biomarkers and getting great
signals noise while maintaining your
great linearity you we have some great
questions coming in
um next question is my understanding is
that you deactivate the 404 in between
rounds that the antibodies would remain
can you comment around cross reactivity
uh yeah so most antibodies that are used
in a cell by study they're direct
conjugates meaning that the dye is
conjugated directly to the primary
antibody and this mitigates any issues
that might occur
or that do occur due to species cross
reactivity
perfect
another question we have for the
multiplex imaging how many colors can
you use what is the limitation
laser filter
i'll take that um
so we have four different channels that
we use along with dapi for registration
so really you can do
for
four biomarkers per round
thank you melinda
and the next question is the cell dive
imager compatible with multiview
i think that's a great question um
so
the cell dive platform
is we're sort of
you know while we recommend a lot of
antibodies where we can be open to the
use of
different
antibody resources
however we have not validated ulta view
on our system
[Music]
and another question we have is there an
upper limit on size of sample with click
well slides
the
the click well the slides um you can you
can almost you can fill a slide almost
completely with tissue
um
and still use the click well um the i
think the only limitation is that there
is a gasket that that forms the well
and so you have to leave a little bit of
room around the edges for that gasket
thank you we have another follow-up is
clickwell compatible with older
instrument models
no so quickwell is only compatible with
the new model
the commercial version of cell dive
well we have time for um one last
question
the question is what kind of stainer do
you use
is manual stain okay
this is a good question um
cell dive is a flexible solution so you
can stain slides however you want to
whether you do it on the bench or you
can use a liquid handler you can use a
side a slide stainer whatever solution
suits your study for example i have a
preferred sort of
hybrid of all of these i prefer to keep
the slides within the click well for
everything but the staining step and
during the staining step i take the
slides out and stain them
in a humidity chamber and then return
them back to the click well so you know
whatever works what whatever
method you prefer in your lab you can
use um
with a click well
thank you and we're actually going to
wrap up with one more um that came up
how is fluorescence quenched between
rounds
and
rick if you're able to answer that
question okay yeah so there's a um
there's a gentle dye inactivation
solution that's used to
um
chemically inactivate the fluorophore
it's validated against cyanine-based
dyes and um
is very tissue preservative
hey thank you so much again both melinda
and rick for your guys time today and
your important research
we'd also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor leica microsystems for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
all their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you have
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed now on demand
libraries will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with any
colleagues or anybody who have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye